hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a very special live
stream that I wanted to do I wanted to
do Oh am i up yet hello hello hi hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to a very special live stream
for me if anyone's there say hi and I
will say hi back to you hello hello
anybody there nobody there oh hi how's
it going hello hi guys welcome welcome
one and all welcome welcome welcome I am
doing a very very special livestream
today for me anyway this game I talked
about it in the video where I I posted
the video where I did a little story
when I was at VidCon hi guys hello my
goodness so many names here hello hello
hello everybody hello so I wanted to do
a quick overview of the game home world
and home world is a game that's very
special to me for the reasons obviously
I stated in that video and I'm loading
it up right now so it'll be ready to go
in just a second but I want to super lag
where are we oh god are we there are we
still here are you all still here are we
all okay I have no idea happy birthday
oh that's loud oh okay
yeah I didn't load up the game yet I
forgot that to go through all the
settings
oh my god it's crashing I swear this
game is good guys I swear this game is
good oh no it is completely crashed
there goes my oopsy poopsy
no no not ever I know you guys can't see
it I know you guys can't see it but
every time I touch something it breaks
okay oh my god
this is so finicky right now Oh rose
again hang on I know you guys can't see
anything I know just give me a second
here I'm getting it all set up and ready
to go apply okay I think we're good
or you just ignore the grumbling and
groaning that you see in the distance
until I get the actual game
but okay the game is up and it'll be
ready to go and just to say let me turn
down the volume for you guys anyway so
this game is home world this game is
part of my childhood and this game is
something that I wanted to bring to you
guys live because I wanted to talk
through it with you like in in in the
most detailed way I can and home world
this is the remastered version so this
is the one with updated graphics from
everything that I saw when I was a kid I
haven't played the updated version so my
mind is still in that childhood
nostalgia where everything was so much
grander than it actually was everything
looked more amazing than it actually did
and everything was fantastic in ways
that you couldn't have seen here so in
this one we're just gonna go through
what is essentially the first levels of
the game so I can talk you through this
because I in this in this like entire
scenario this know that wasn't sure yeah
I didn't load this up before so in this
entire scenario to give you an idea of
the entire world I'm not sure if it'll
do the opening cinematic of it but if it
does I'll let it play but because it got
the narrator on like the opening
cinematic
100 years ago a satellite detected an
object under the sands of the great
desert an expedition was set
[Music]
an ancient starship buried in the sand
well this game so much
deep inside the ruin was a single stone
that would change the course of our
history forever
on the stone was etched a galactic map
and a single word more ancient and the
clans themselves hiigara our home
Raiders so good oh god he's so good
there's everything about this game I
love and the opening cinematic is not
done yet so
the clans were united and a massive
colony ship was designed construction
would take 60 years it would demand new
technologies new industries and new
sacrifices
the greatest of these was made by the
scientist Karen's eject yourself
permanently integrated into the colony
ship as its living core she is now Fleet
command
the promise of the guide stone United
the entire population every mind became
focused on the true origin of our people
every effort on the construction of this
ship that would seek it out among the
stars
here we go
this opening sequence whoo my mind as a
kid this is the whole concept of just
flying around in space like and this was
like I hadn't played a lot of 3d games
at that point and just like all they're
talking about his leg reading prep for
the ship launch so that's like that it's
probably really loud I wouldn't doubt if
it's really loud so please let me know
if the volume is okay and all that stuff
because I don't know if it is or I've I
don't know if it's too loud and old but
yeah when I was a kid uh when I first
saw the mothership radar status
[Music]
reserving
struction on line insertion cryogenic
subsections k2j online
[Music]
Katie s online
scaffold control stand by for alignment
[Music]
this music is called Adagio for Strings
by the way for you music heads it's oh
gods one of my favorite pieces of string
music ever
[Music]
standby release control
Paul Keller for bankers
it looks so pretty
it's so pretty
the mothership has cleared the scaffold
we are way and you like the sense of
scale of this thing doesn't even
translate it looks big here but it
doesn't translate those little ships
that you stopped popping out those are
entire fighter jets coming out of this
thing
big ones oh it's so big and beautiful
okay I'm sorry
just I get so excited about this game I
agree I said love this game so much I
love it I love everything about it and
there we have it
okay so now we're actually in the game
and once you are able to actually go
into the game and you were actually able
to data and generate mission objectives
Oh
hyperdrive test several trials must be
completed by building the primary
research ship resource processing by
harvesting the asteroids provide oh okay
hyperspace module charging 35% capacity
and rising lugu mothership will be ready
for the hyperdrive test and done good
look at him go these are the resource
collectors I know you don't care about
the resource collectors but I care about
the resource collectors we will be
monitoring formation performance being
provided here assign of formation to
your fighters and destroy the drones
yeah destroy those drills screw those
drones get those at all they're sucking
the horn
oh that looks so good God man prove that
so much that looks so good
oh man the last time I play this was was
it
it was eight nine years ago now was the
last time I played this game oh man if
you haven't seen the video of me talking
about this game and why this game is so
important to me you can check out the
video on my channel called the story of
why I love space because this game is
literally why I love space if you see
like the magnificence of Lee in the
universe and and what's weird is like
you zoom out and it's like these tiny
little specks these tiny specks here are
my scouts they have to put a triangle
over them cuz they're so goddamn small
then you zoom in and it's like oh dude
oh you look at these little bastards and
it's like oh my god you want to know
where the guy is in this one right there
that's the cockpit this is huge guns and
these are the scouts
oh the planets there you can see the
lights love it so much
[Music]
anyway I just want to show you guys oh
yeah and I forgot the map isn't Alan
what is map I forget that forget what
map is space that's right space so you
gotta go over here you got a fall a
middle click to do all that stuff all
the minor and then don't drone those
drones you can give them oh wait no Han
I forgot what is the oh it's been so
long all right so I click to attack if I
could get them no don't move oh yeah oh
yeah 3d maneuvers like shift to go up
and down because you're in space it's 3d
this whole concept it blew the mind oh
oh offensive formation I Delta formation
that my favorite was always claw
formation oh there they go they're
aggressive today oh and then they would
go in attack runs and they were just
strafe back and forth until all the
enemies go boom
oh it's so cool alright so kill those
guys
kill them good formation trial complete
flight analysis shows a 22% increase in
combat performance the next trial will
test the effectiveness of tactics yes
Dan by to begin tactics trial so we're
not just here we're evasive tactics I'm
not gonna do target drones here I'm not
gonna do a live stream of the entirety
of this game I don't want I don't want
to see point set you up for this point
what I do want to walk you through is
the the initial campaign and what what
like just how this game not only from a
sense of scale of like the the world
that you're in and it is a really
impressive sense of scale but also just
from like the way the story interacts
you just from right from the get-go it
sets the stakes so high like this whole
planet I don't know if you even you guys
even caught it like hey attack things I
think move an attack are they going to
attack yeah they're going to attack so
like not only if you caught it in the
opening sequence like it set up the
the stakes for this a United every
single clan on this planet from a
derelict ship that had a guide stone of
their homeworld they needed definer they
had to find it they had to find out who
they were and it took eighty to a
hundred years I forget exactly how long
it took but it took lifetimes just to
build this one ship so that they could
go and they could find it so good
everything about Italy next trial will
test the performance of the salvaged
Corvette this is like this is like an
opening and tutorial gameplay style
thing so it's like it's both the
gameplay of the game and the the style
of it itself so I am gonna calm down I
promise I'll calm down thank you so much
yeah but I just absolutely 100% adore
this game let me just hang on one sec
sorry I'll get right back into it there
we go all right so now what was it oh
yeah I got a build
I got a build a board Corvette so your
mothership is the thing that obviously
builds all of your crafts so you build
doodly-doo you've got your different
shapes with designated different like
Fighters Corvettes you eventually get
frigates you get capital class ships
resourcing non-combat for research and
whatnot but what's even more amazing as
this ship can produce other capital
class ships carriers destroyers like
it's it's it's insane what comes out of
this the first got a bill to salvage
Corvette to be able to finish out this
tutorial these guys are probably idling
because these resources have been
drained and I don't think there's any
other resources to be had anywhere ooh
yeah so this this game is
super-important to me I'll recap like
the story of why when I was
when I was young my dad bought me this
game and when I when I grew up like this
game was very important to me I loved it
a lot but you know it was this game but
then after my dad passed away I came
back to this game and we collected like
I I saw it for what it really was and
like the scope of it and the scale of it
and that's what really really got me so
happy about this game and like made me
really appreciate space and so I I just
can't say in so many words about it but
we're gonna get through this because
this is this is I'll admit this opening
sequence I've done it so many times it's
boring to me so I'm gonna get through
this because the more important things
happen later because we have only a
certain number of ejected we got to
capture this one we got to build a
research ship I forgot about that should
have done that a while ago research [ __ ]
alright I mean this guy is gonna Salvage
this probe it's just teaching you basic
concepts of that game not not the most
important thing in the world yeah get
that Oh get it I always loved just like
watching these things really closely
like just watching him going through
space doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo
oh so good oh and there was a way to
break the game obviously if you build
too many things there are no other
resources besides that if you build too
many things before you ever built the
research car the salvaged Corvette you
are stuck and dead in the water and you
can't progress and after we start the
level just one of those things it's just
like unforgiving and I kind of like it
about that alright so after that and
once the research ship is built which
it's almost done then I can actually
research something because I know that's
what it wants me to do hyperspace module
I haven't seen how they do the the new
effects for this good luck everyone good
luck the first time the hyperspace is
the first time they've no idea if it's
gonna work they've no idea oh yeah and
then once you press that button you
actually have to wait for all of your
ships to dock I mean don't have to cuz
they have to dock or else it'll all blow
up you know what I mean the fighters are
coming back okay oh I want to see it oh
oh look at that it's gone oh it's going
[Music]
alright so where we're going now we're
doing a test jump we're not going all
the way to hey Gaara right now you
couldn't do that well hyperspace systems
operating at full power
if the hyperspace targeting system is
accurate we will emerge in close
proximity to the support vessel cárcel M
this ship has spent the past 10 years
traveling on conventional drives to
reach the outer car rack system the car
Salim will monitor the quantum waveform
as we return to normal space in the
system tuning our drive control systems
if the hyperspace module malfunctions
the car Selene will provide assistance
in resupply mission objectives will be
to dock with the support vessel in order
to complete adjustments to the
mothership in her drives can you imagine
that going out 10 10 years just for a
test 10 years just sailing through the
blackness just for a test so now we're
on the outskirts of the caraxes tomb
which is where we just came from
complete all systems nominal and the
quantum wave effect has dissipated
we thank you Karen the support ship is
not here fleet command will signal the
kharsa limb while we confirm our current
position this is the mothership calling
support vessel cárcel in come in please
we've missed jumped and are requesting
your beacon
this is the mothership calling support
vessel car salim please respond this is
where you get the first hints that
things aren't what they sealed up the
car Slim's automated beacon send a probe
to make contact and re-establish
communications because yeah you know
what I'm not even gonna say anything
because it would just be a spoiler so
you need to build the probe which are
super cheap I'm sending my guys out to
do their thing but also I'm gonna push
for a long bill from father tomorrow so
we got the probe so you send the probe
out it goes super fast right all the way
over to there let's follow this bad boy
because this bad boy is fast go about it
oh god he looks so cool now oh they made
him so streamlines in the original game
you could actually play as one of two
different versions of the mother ships
and all the ships were different made no
sense story wise but you know I always
played is the other version for some
reason when my first step we're getting
close we're already almost there
[Music]
oh when I first saw this it
I was shook I was a shook little boy I
was like oh my god it's all broke Oh
so pretty they did it so good update
oh but in my mind it looks no different
because in my mind this is how it always
looked Oh - try it try it is under
attack engage incoming units the other
ship must be defended oh it will be oh
it will be Oh it'll be defended all
right are you go over that no intercept
intercept intercept intercept intercept
the intercept okay
engage engage all right so this is the
first taste of like actual combat and
the beauty of it is like all these ships
that are just fly-in everywhere they're
barely more than little pixels in there
you're fighting out a fight to the death
I was like watching one - seeing one of
the group and just seeing how they fly
around and they're like that guy stood
no yeah I want to see the destruction oh
hey those guys are tearing us up this
guy don't look so good he's going down
Oh buddy you all right there buddy he's
struggling
can I always feel bad when will scouts
died it's like there's a guy in there
there's a fighter blues guys tough guys
going for it maybe should dock back
hey how about you know my research
vessel get off of that
take out the standard Corvette oh ho ho
unrelenting fire see how that looks oh
man good that guy yeah you have to like
plan like everything was very meticulous
because you had a plan the order of
which fit because if you missed it like
you had to strafe out and then come back
round to it like it was legitimately
difficult also why am I not researching
anything I should be I'm not Bo okay so
these guys you got to get rid of the
Corvettes because the Corvettes are the
ones that are actually attacking the
mothership not that there's any actual
damage like that would be able to happen
to that but even so
and Danzo Danzo get that last guy see if
I can zoom in on this guy
it loses lose ugly bastard with tiger
stripes I so cooler things use anyway ah
and this is a taste of it this is just
like the start of it oh is that guy
running away I forget what it is what do
I need to do add they're doing fine yeah
oh look resource man's coming in for
duck nice good job good job man
any more research all right yeah but
this is this is what it is alone so much
so much
are you done yet sorry I was waxing
poetic along interceptors are great by
the way I love interceptors and whatever
I guess they're fun copy
come on just finish them off at the full
power
yeah Scouts aren't very powerful so
Scouts are just like nothing where's
that intercept there is this is my boy
interceptors I'm a boy they're they're
they're like only 30 units more than the
other ones but they're way more powerful
that should be the last one it's
destroyed yeah interceptor complete the
kharsa looma has been destroyed heavy
weapon damage is visible on the
remaining fragment a salvage Corvette
must be sent to retrieve the mission
data recorder will do alright so now we
gotta send these guys out and I'm gonna
send them out with a little squadron
consider pretty sure there was a I'm not
100% sure but there might have been an
ambush waiting for me over there either
way they're a squadron now so go get em
boy he's reporting alright I think
there's a way you can like assign them
to protect ya aggressive I want to do I
always like aggressive but shouldn't now
come on move move move get over there
get over there alright they're gonna go
but obviously the salvage Corvette is
way slower so these guys are gonna go
over there because I'm not our percent
sure but there might be something bad
Aven
maybe some of the bed over there waiting
for us wait whoa what was that what was
that I saw that something over there
okay anyway not important
confirmed just slow piece of crap if I
had to remember all this I used to when
I played this over and over again I used
to just automatically like know where to
send him exactly where to send them when
to send them but anyway so I sorry I get
so distracted by this game all the time
but this game like you guys can see why
I love this game
it is a real-time strategy it is yeah it
definitely is it's a 100% real-time
strategy but unlike any other real-time
strategy I've ever played like just the
not to mention like the the technical
aspects of 3d but also like the unlike
the not so technical aspects of like
micromanaging these guys would be a
monumental task because you can't
exactly control where they go you can do
combat maneuvers and like it with your
capital ships you can definitely do
strafing runs and stuff like that and
kind of control it in that way but when
it comes to more detailed like more oh
yeah yeah they're gonna accompany this
guy wherever the salvage Corvette goes
well one of them anyway yeah so like
when it came to this hi hi guys hello hi
guys there's either but when it came to
this like just the sheer scale of it I
loved it so much I that's what you have
intercepted course with the cars to live
call direction of the salvage team as a
primary objective oh hey that is I
returned the Scout was going to mission
recorder that's why I'm here
I knew a knee carrier they appear to be
reinforcing their squadrons of Fighters
and Corvettes with it uh-huh
how about that good for them or it clear
uh-oh I can make Corvettes I was late
for Vince alright so these guys are
doing their things
they'll be fine there's really nothing
that Scout is like sacrificing himself
Wow one-man army over here you know you
could go back home but you're you'll be
remembered I suppose yeah so you could
potentially destroy this guy whoa yeah
so this is an example of a capital class
ship like it's a it is very technically
a carrier and it can produce fighters so
I can build a carrier that can produce
fighters later on the game right it's
just such a smart way of doing RTS stuff
like you obviously build an armory to
build stuff in other games or whatever
it is you build a barracks in StarCraft
you know but the fact that you can build
like another capital ship just makes so
much goddamn sense because the capital
ship is a ship itself and it flies oh
he's almost back so that'll be the last
one and then it'll be another cinematic
and then we have to get back cuz this
ain't gonna be good
I know the graphics are so good I mean
compared to what they were I mean I know
there's obviously games with like more
full to realistic and who knows what
this is in terms of photo realism but of
the music - it's so weird but it just
fits
[Music]
sir they're coming in fast
they're getting through reaching across
all deck Bailey
hyperdrive
it always unnerved me how calm they
sounded because it was just like well
they're under attack and they're dying
it's like pilots and like any any plane
like they have to be calm anyway so
that's that you're gonna talk to me now
there it is
organize a defensive force to protect
the mothership okay all right so I gotta
take care of these guys they're coming
in whatever it's fine I'll be fine I
just got to build more I can build
Corvettes like Corvettes Hollyer yes
Corvettes are gonna be the best thing
magnet where's my interceptors okay
interceptor squad Scout squad doodly-doo
okay one your aggressive fire it will go
crawl and do it once I get more like
actual other shifts like frigates
frigates you need their big somewhere in
between a capital ship and a fighter
like this they are like they can be ion
frigates which are I cannot wait to see
the ion beam in the new version of this
but I'm like I don't want to like get
too crazy about because this does look
like homeworld 2 which was a good game
and you know the secret I love the first
one more but you know obviously you get
what you get Roger see if I can go
actually kill this carrier
I got one striker good job lock it come
on good for group two strike group
attack order confirmed
so I'm gonna have the scouts mop up
these guys there we go those guys I
wonder uh there was a way smear
formation houses for your formation is
great because then you can just
it'll they'll literally just sit there
around around the the capital ship and
they will just orbit them and shoot them
until they're dead if they lose all
defensive capability and sphere
formation but hey hey lot of firepower
to destroy oh I forgot the capital ship
oh I forgot the capital ship can also
shoot forgot about that
that's great too alright let's see yeah
someone's someone's been eating yep
yep yep all right anyway so I did that
wrong but I got Corvettes over here that
are gonna take care of this guy Roger
all right what else can we build we're
gonna need a lot more interceptors under
way oh no and I need to cancel some of
those there we go they're done how many
more we got all right we could just get
these goods you left once this guy is
dead and then it's just this guy oh did
the other guy already
oh did he bug out already he did okay so
the other carrier already jumped away so
he's gone then we just have these guys
left and then we can take care of him
then we're good to go
oh yeah you did you do go doc oh oh wait
no doesn't one more there where do you
come from
oh finish them off come on we gotta get
out of here we got to get back to the
homeworld
barriers oh come on how many more of
them are there gets get rid of that guy
Gobert alright so they get that guy and
they got this guy okay man finish your
mouth already
all right there we go come on finish
something there is always a dodgy one
there he goes goodness gracious there's
so many of these guys they're just all
over the place
where did they jump to oh can I just not
see oh I was in the wrong space okay
jeez do I have to kill that carrier then
let's see how I would Oh destroy I do
need to destroy the carrier oh okay
well that makes sense I thought that was
what I was supposed to do then what was
going wrong before yeah either way he's
gonna keep that ended up in here attack
vector late in Earth's are clear alright
he's gonna take a bit longer than I
thought because I was going about it the
wrong way I was pretty sure that you
were supposed to destroy that but I
don't think yeah the carrier doesn't
have any defensive capabilities does he
and that wouldn't make any sense at all
all right I'm just gonna have the
Corvette's hammer the carrier there and
hopefully they'll be enough to know it
does have guns
oh do have guns that's no good oh yeah
they got their their missile frigates
and missile Corvettes
sorry these are all things that you guys
don't know about like I know these these
uh stupid goddamn jerks
hang on let me focus on this in
concentrate interceptor coming here and
assist get rid of these missile
Corvettes they're tearing us up straight
group attack order confirmed you know
and I'm gonna I'm gonna hammer all
firepower on the carrier because if
that's the only thing that I got to do
then that's what we're gonna do
no it doesn't have guns does it them oh
I'm so stupid no he does have guns I
know that you can see the impact of the
bullets on this thing but I just
couldn't remember it like it was
actually shooting back or not well
that's sad for group one maybe they
should have been better oh man that
thing man we are not doing enough damage
to the thing
[Music]
the student combat stations friendlies
under fire
moving in ready acknowledged
Roger Missy if I can steal this Corvette
no already on oh wait no yeah yeah I can
maybe yeah get it get it get it get it
get it get it get it get it get it
you got it yeah get it oh you should
he's stupid yeah you're on our team now
who's the pilot and then gone yeah
you're mine now
ah yeah yeah okay so I just got to get
rid of these who's more guys to
intercept Roger I'm I am we're all out
of oh no we're not all out okay we
there's still some oh yeah the gas
clouds that's right okay looking good
huh what do we got here hell yeah
standard Corvette we robbed them all
right we just gotta get rid of this this
guy but I think we can sneak and steal
actually if we can steal that one then
we can better attack this one yeah
because if we can get that missile
Corvette that's gonna be helpful go get
him buddy oh we're chasing mounting the
system oh yeah you get out of here we
have too many collectors here expect
delays uh yeah okay whatever
this guy's gonna be able to get this
game nabim don't kill him yet oh no you
some what that don't kill no you
interceptor bastard oh you douche oh you
do Sh
all right keep hammering that guy I
really don't think we're gonna be able
to kill him because it's just not enough
that was it I didn't need to kill him I
could never remember that it's been nine
years I guess all right we're getting
out of here we gotta go quick doc we
gotta go we gotta go we're out of here
baby right here
we're out here okay
there's where things get really really
really intense
hi guys hello hi guys yeah oh I'm glad
you liked the game I'm glad you like it
I love it a lot that's so cool it's on
Steam if you want to get it it's on
Steam analysis of wreckage reveals the
hostile units are using strike craft
ranging from fighters to combat
Corvettes all pilots will be briefed in
case hostiles have penetrated farther
into the car axis tum' on our return to
car act the final outfit of the
mothership must be accelerated in order
to defend against possible future
attacks
many major mothership systems are still
incomplete we will notify car axial
defense system of this possible threat
the mothership will then dock that the
scaffold for repairs
stand by for hyperspace exit to car rack
no one's left
everything's gone
carick is burning kuraki is being
consumed by a fire store the scaffold
has been destroyed all orbital
facilities destroyed significant debris
ring and local rock orbit receiving no
communication from anywhere in the
system
not even beacons wait on the maintenance
frequency I'm getting a signal from the
cryo tray systems in orbit one of them
is suffering a massive malfunction the
cryo trays are under attack defend them
moving to intercept ready it is likely
they were involved in the destruction of
captured at least one vessel for
interrogation and destroy the rest yeah
so the entire world is gone every single
population is gone and I'm taking you
with me
hey ba how about you shut up and you
come with me you're coming with me
yeah Nana don't even think of it oh I
need to I forgot I needed to oh I forgot
you need to do for that oh no I'm an
a-hole I forgot you needed to for a
frigate oh no I'm gonna lose a cryo tray
I always prided myself in being able to
sell like save the cryo trays oh I
forgot I was supposed to build that in
the last one before I left
oh that's fine it's not gonna be like
world destroying for me it's just sad
[Music]
yeah cuz if I would have had to I would
have been able to immediately do that
but stupid me forgot oh well it's fine I
get over here you got work to do come on
come on come on come on come on no no
not the mothership oh my god doing oh
the mother she was kidding involved
alright so cool because even the frigate
you can see it's actually trying to
shoot at that tiny target and it only
hits I lost the car damn it it doesn't
have any impact on the game it really
doesn't but like I always like I took it
as a point of pride I wanted to make
sure that I had all the crowd trays
secured hey come on be nice to that guy
be nice yeah don't shoot him
alright now this guy is mine you come
with me there you go that's a damn [ __ ]
but once we get this guy in here you'll
see what happened and then I'll explain
it because obviously I'm not gonna do a
full playthrough the game but then I'll
explain it but I mean it'll probably
explain itself because it's pretty
pretty clear gosh-darn frigate
[Music]
I don't even know if the Arthur any
resources to collect here I don't think
so there's nothing here though I guess
there are yeah always is I said that guy
is gonna be slowly sucked into the
mothership there
I know space i know i know space ah
space guys enemy units neutralized
begins salvaging the cryo trays hostile
vessel captured crew intern
interrogation is underway while
searching the enemy ships computer
systems we came across these flavor
Corning's standby for playback
[Music]
analysis of the recording indicates that
the karach missile defenses heavily
damaged the attacking fleet however we
have concluded that at present they can
still easily defeat us we have therefore
plotted a course to a deep space
asteroid belt there we can hide and
prepare our fleet for an assault
[Music]
all right so let me explain this and a
was it this moment this or we have
reverse-engineered the drive technology
and developed two new ships plans for a
third vessel are underway but will
require frigate chassis research so let
me explain this
this like this is the moment where I got
hooked into this game more than I ever
had because I'm gonna explain this game
and with Chama try without spoilers but
at this point like I don't know if it's
avoidable this game was so much more
than that by the time I got to this
point because they burned this planet
because there was an ancient ancient
ancient treaty an ancient law that these
people villag Ahrens the people who live
there and were subsequently burned were
banished because in this universe
there's only a few civilizations that
are capable of warp technology the
ability to have warp is everything you
wouldn't be able to go to the other
planets if you didn't have it but I
forget what it was they specifically did
but for some reason these people were
banished from their homeworld and their
homeworld was taken over by the very
people that burned this planet and
fundamentally just wiped him out like
almost made them entirely extinct each
one of these cryo trees has a hundred
thousand people in it in addition from
those crowd traits to the crowd traits
already on the mothership that's all
that's left maybe a maybe two million
people of this entire civilization left
in this ship with anger in their hearts
trying to get back home and as the story
unfolds throughout the rest of this game
you travel this huge unimaginably big
universe trying desperately to survive
and struggle and maintain with what
limited resources you have and your
resource carryover from every mission
your resources carry over you only have
what you have and what you managed to
take from each and every part if you
waste your resources building things
that aren't gonna help you survive you
won't make it
like just the beauty of that concept the
struggle and and knowing that this
universe was huge like that's that's
what made it beautiful so incredibly
beautiful and that's what I loved about
and this game is long this game is like
probably I don't eight hours long maybe
ten depending on how how slow you take
it if you take your time if this could
last up to like maybe twenty hours but
I'm gonna leave this it here cuz I just
wanted to give you guys a lot of people
were asking you to do a let's play this
and I didn't want to do a full let's
play of it because it was something very
important to me but I think this is a
good trade-off a personal like very
personal for me like little introduction
of this game to you guys and it's such a
good game I love it so so much not only
just for like my history with it but
because the game itself is this
beautiful but I'm gonna leave this here
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this I
really want to know like what you think
of this game if you buy it for yourself
and you play it later let me know what
you think of it it is a good game and
like I'm not sponsored by them in any
way I'm not I I make nothing if you buy
it like it's just this is it's beautiful
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching I will have another video
out today don't think that I'm just
trying to skip out on the noon video the
livestream or nothing I've actually got
another one that I want to put out today
but just thank you guys so much for
giving me the chance to introduce this
game to you I hope you all have a
wonderful day expect the next video in
like a couple hours or so but thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye bye
bye guys bye bye bye bye